then McCarl city youth council has
existed since 1998 the youth council is
a group of youth aged 12 and 24 who act
as advocates for all young people in
Invercargill the youth council ensure
that young people's voices get heard by
the council and provides a youth
perspective on the council's decision
making here on the youth council we aim
to help organize events and projects
involving young people having a public
voice find create and push for things
for young people to do look at ways to
improve the social and physical
environment I want to help participate
in setting up things for youth to do and
the holidays after school things like
that youth organisations youth based
organizations cafes gaming lenders
things like that dream um pouco goes to
the youth council has been a fantastic
opportunity for me to involve myself in
making Invercargill more aware of issues
for young people and sleeping up to make
a difference in our community youth
council meets fortnightly on wednesdays
from 4pm to 530 p.m. during the school
term on the youth council we are offered
the opportunity to be involved in many
activities including attending trainings
and meetings passing information onto
our networks like our schools be
involved in representing and the cargo
at youth activities around the country I
joined the youth council was one of the
local nominees I was nominated by a
friend of mine down at the social
services and they told me to come along
and make a difference here in
Invercargill I was hoping to create more
fun activities for youth to do in this
bed time because I hear of a lot of
youth just sitting around playing
PlayStation the Youth Council consists
of up to 25 members to be a member you
will need to be between 12 to 24 years
of age live an or attend school training
or be employed within the Invercargill
city council area have the ability to
work with other people and work in a
team be proactive be committed to
attending meetings regularly be
nominated by your school or a youth
organization or you can volunteer to be
a member we aim to have as broad
possible group of young people
representing me appears and under cargo
it's been a great experience being on
the Youth Council I gained a social
conscience confidence in public speaking
I learned proper meetings procedure and
make some great new friends more sense
of lift I've managed to get a job as a
trainee accountant at a local accounting
firm and i'm currently sitting on a
community panel which i don't think i
would have been able to do without being
a part of the council to be selected for
youth council it's simple the call for
nominations or applications for youth
council members will be made in
august-september each year for the
following year secondary schools within
the city are invited to nominate two
members representing each school
applications for additional members will
be sought by public advertising and
promotion youth counselors will be
selected on their ability to demonstrate
leadership advocacy governance and
service skills for more information you
can see the youth council webpage on the
council website also keep up to date
with what the youth council is up to on
the Facebook page